se encuentran India, Rusia, Sudáfrica, Brasil y China
que no alcanzan el 7 %
y en muchos casos retroceden.
El crecimiento de la economía importa.
Con el crecimiento,
los países y las sociedades ingresan en un ciclo virtuoso
de movilidad ascendente, de oportunidad y mejores niveles de vida.
Sin el crecimiento, los países se contraen y se atrofian,
no solo en los anales de estadísticas económicas
también en el significado de la vida y en cómo es vivida.
El crecimiento económico afecta profundamente al individuo.
Si el crecimiento disminuye,
se pone en riesgo el progreso humano
y aumenta el riesgo de inestabilidad política y social,
las sociedades se apagan, se vuelven vulgares y empequeñecen.
El contexto es importante.
Los países de mercados emergentes
no necesitan crecer al mismo nivel que los países desarrollados.
Sé que a algunos de Uds. le parecerá una proposición riesgosa.
Hay algunos aquí
que se sentirán desilusionados
por lo que pasa en el mundo
y se lo atribuyen a la economía.
Se preocupan por la superpoblación del planeta.
Observando las recientes estadísticas de la ONU
que habrá 11 000 millones de personas en el mundo
antes de que decline en el 2100,
Uds. se preocupan porque esto puede afectar a los recursos naturales
como tierra fértil, agua potable, energía y minerales.
También se preocupan por la degradación del medio ambiente
y se preocupan por cómo el hombre,
encarnado en las corporaciones mundiales,
se ha vuelto ambicioso y corrupto.
Pero estoy aquí para decirles que el crecimiento económico
ha sido el eje de los cambios en los estándares de vida
de millones de personas en el mundo.
Y, lo más importante,
no es solo el crecimiento de la economía conducido por el capitalismo.
La definición de capitalismo, sencillamente,
es que los factores de producción,
como el comercio, la industria, el capital y el empleo,
están en manos del sector privado y no en el Estado.
Es esencial que comprendamos
que fundamentalmente la crítica no es a la economía y su crecimiento
sino al capitalismo.
Para provocar un crecimiento en la economía a largo plazo,
tendremos que conseguirlo con una mejor postura económica.
El crecimiento económico necesita al capitalismo,
y trabajar adecuadamente.
Como mencioné hace un momento,
el núcleo del sistema capitalista ha sido definido por el sector privado.
Y esto es una dicotomía muy simplista.
El capitalismo es bueno; el no capitalismo es malo.
En la experiencia práctica,
el capitalismo es un amplio espectro.
Hay países como China,
que han aplicado más el capitalismo de estado,
y hay países como Estados Unidos
que son capitalistas de mercado.
Nuestros esfuerzos para criticar el sistema capitalista
se han enfocado en países como China
que no son completamente capitalistas de mercado.
Sin embargo, hay una razón y una preocupación
para enfocarnos en formas más puras de capitalismo,
particularmente las practicadas en EE.UU.
Esto es muy importante
porque este tipo de capitalismo
ha sido fuertemente acusado
de promover la corrupción
y también
de incrementar la inequidad de ingresos;
la idea de que unos pocos se benefician a expensas de la mayoría.
Las preguntas más importantes que debemos abordar son:
¿Cómo arreglar el capitalismo
para que pueda ayudarnos en el crecimiento de la economía
y que nos ayude a resolver los problemas sociales?
Para pensar en esta idea tenemos que preguntarnos,
¿cómo funciona hoy el capitalismo?
Simplemente,
el capitalismo se basa en aumentar la utilidad individual;
un individuo egoísta que va detrás de lo que quiere.
Solo después de que su utilidad haya aumentado,
deciden que es importante
brindar apoyo a otros contratos sociales.
En este sistema los gobiernos cobran impuestos,
y usan parte de sus ingresos para financiar programas sociales,
aceptando que el rol del gobierno no es solo la regulación
sino también ser juez de los bienes sociales.
Sin embargo,
este marco de referencia
de dos etapas
es la base por donde debemos empezar
a pensar en mejorar el modelo capitalista.
Yo diría que hay dos aspectos en este desafío.
Primero,
podemos tomar las políticas de la derecha
y ver qué sería beneficioso
para lograr mejorar el capitalismo.
En particular,
las políticas de derecha
suelen hacer hincapié en las transferencias condicionales,
donde pagamos y premiamos a personas por hacer cosas
que creemos que pueden ayudarnos a hacer crecer la economía.
Por ejemplo,
al enviar a los niños al colegio,
los padres pueden ganar dinero,
o al mantener a sus hijos vacunados e inmunes,
los padres podrían recibir dinero.
Más allá del debate
de si debemos o no pagarle a las personas
por hacer lo que pensamos que deberían hacer,
lo que importa es que pagar por lo producido
ha dado algunos resultados positivos
en lugares como México,
en Brasil
y en programas piloto en Nueva York.
Aunque también hay beneficios
y cambios importantes en las políticas de la izquierda.
Discusiones de que el gobierno debería expandir su rol y responsabilidad
para no estar tan limitado
y que el gobierno debería ser más un juez
del factor de producción
se ha vuelto muy común con el éxito de China.
Pero también, hemos empezado a debatir
sobre que el rol del sector privado
debería dejar de ser solo obtener ganancia
e involucrarse más en contribuir a programas sociales.
Al igual que los programas de responsabilidad social empresaria,
aunque en menor escala,
se están moviendo en esa dirección.
Por supuesto que las políticas de izquierda han borrado los límites
entre el gobierno, las ONGs y el sector privado.
Dos ejemplos de esto son los Estados Unidos del siglo XIX,
cuando el despliegue de infraestructura
se basó en asociaciones públicas y privadas.
Recientemente,
la llegada de Internet ha demostrado al mundo
que lo público y lo privado pueden ayudar juntos a la sociedad.
Mi mensaje principal para Uds. es:
No podemos seguir tratando de resolver los desafíos económicos
con dogmas o con ideología innecesaria.
Para crear un crecimiento sustentable de la economía a largo plazo
y resolver los problemas sociales que siguen apoderándose del mundo,
tendremos que abrir la mente
a lo que puede funcionar.
Finalmente,
tenemos que aceptar que la ideología es enemiga del crecimiento.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
BG: Quiero hacer unas preguntas, Dambisa,
porque podríamos responder a lo último que dijiste
que el crecimiento es una ideología,
y que es posiblemente la ideología dominante de hoy.
¿Qué le dirías a los que te dijeran eso?
DM: Bueno, creo que eso es verdad,
y creo que estamos discutiendo sobre eso.
Hay mucho trabajo con respecto a la felicidad
y otros métodos usados para medir el éxito de la gente
y las mejoras en los niveles de vida.
Así que creo que debemos estar abiertos
a lo que podría mejorar el nivel de vida de las personas
y seguir reduciendo la pobreza en el mundo.
BG: Estás pidiendo un crecimiento que rehabilite,
pero la única forma de que suceda
sin comprometer la capacidad del planeta
de perdurar en el tiempo,
es que el crecimiento económico
en cierta forma se desacople del uso de recursos subyacente.
¿Notas que sucede eso?
DM: Soy optimista acerca de la habilidad y el ingenio humanos.
Creo que si nos limitamos
al uso de recursos escasos
que conocemos hoy,
seríamos pesimistas
y estaríamos preocupados por cómo es el mundo.
Sin embargo, hemos visto al Club de Roma,
hemos visto reclamos anteriores
de que el mundo se quedará sin recursos
y sabemos que eso no es válido.
Pero con ingenio podríamos ver la desalinización,
podríamos reinvertir en energía,
para obtener mejores resultados.
Por eso, en ese sentido,
soy optimista acerca de la capacidad humana.
BG: Lo que me sorprende
de tus propuestas de crecimiento rehabilitador
y tomando una dirección diferente
es que estás sugiriendo arreglar el capitalismo con más capitalismo,
poniendo un precio al buen comportamiento como incentivo
o desarrollando un rol mayor en los asuntos sociales.
¿Es esto lo que sugieres?
DM: Sugiero que seamos abiertos de mente.
Creo que ocurre
que los modelos tradicionales de crecimiento económico
no funcionan como nos gustaría.
Creo que no es casualidad
que la economía más grande del mundo, la de Estados Unidos,
tenga democracia,
una democracia liberal, como núcleo de su posición política
y que tenga capitalismo de mercado libre,
al punto de que es libre,
capitalismo de mercado libre como postura económica.
La segunda economía más grande es China.
No ha priorizado la democracia
y tiene un capitalismo de Estado, que plantea un modelo distinto.
Estos dos países, con modelos políticos completamente diferentes
y modelos económicos completamente diferentes,
tienen cifras iguales de desigualdad en el ingreso
medido como coeficiente Gini.
Creo que deberíamos discutir sobre eso,
porque no está del todo claro
qué modelo deberíamos adoptar,
y creo que debería haber más diálogo
y más humildad acerca de lo que sabemos e ignoramos.
BG: Última pregunta, el COP21 está en París.
Si pudieras enviar un tuit
a los jefes de Estado y a las delegaciones que están allí,
¿qué les dirías?
DM: Les hablaría de ser abiertos de mente.
Como saben,
las cuestiones relativas al medio ambiente
han estado en la agenda muchas veces,
en Copenhague, en el '72 en Estocolmo,
y seguimos revisando estos temas
en parte porque no hay un acuerdo,
hay una escisión
entre lo que piensan los países desarrollados
y lo que quieren los países de mercados emergentes.
Los países con mercados emergentes deben hacer crecer su economía
para que no tengamos inseguridad política en esos países.
Los países desarrollados reconocen
que tienen una responsabilidad importante
no solo de controlar sus emisiones de CO2
y a parte de la degradación a la que contribuyen en el mundo
sino también la de marcar tendencia en I+D.
Así que tienen que discutir eso también.
Pero en esencia, no puede haber
una asignación de políticas a los mercados emergentes
sin que los países desarrollados
observen lo que hacen
en términos de oferta y demanda en los mercados desarrollados.
BG: Dambisa, gracias por venir a TED. DM: Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)